so reports just came in at 3.2 8 million
Americans just apply for unemployment
and to just kind of put things in
perspective the second number biggest
number ever of people applying for
unemployment was in October of 1982
where six hundred and fifty nine
thousand people applied for unemployment
we went from 659 to three point two
eight million a hundred thousand
Californians every day are applying for
unemployment especially now that they
announced the 2.2 trillion dollar
stimulus which some are saying it's
$1,000 a month some of the reports
you're reading it's six hundred dollars
a week whatever the number is that's
where we are today so when you're
looking at this stuff this is not
something we're accustomed to this is
not a number we're used to having this
kind of unemployment but at the same
time I was having a conversation with a
few different guys in Pat how do you
protect yourself against a loss like
this I mean you're in the insurance
business you're in the anticipation
business
what are you doing someone like this
what's the best kind of insurance for
something like this it is in life it is
an auto insurance it isn't you know
homeowners insurance
it isn't cellphone insurance it isn't
any desktop although that stuff is got a
place for it the most important thing
today for a time like this is income
protection insurance and income
protection insurance is based on a few
things that you need to do so let me set
that part aside let me give you a
complete different side that we have to
look at look in 2001 9/11 happens 2008
market crashes 2020 we have the pandemic
2001 in 2020 have a lot in common
because they're both a Black Swan nobody
could have predicted it 2008 a lot of
experts could have predicted it that's
what big short movie came up so what
would you do at a time like this there's
three different types of people today
the first group are those that are
relying on the stimulus to come I can't
wait for my unemployment and $1,000
check in the $600 a week for 39 weeks
that's awesome I can't wait for this I'm
going to stay home I'm going to catch up
on movies I'm going to do all this other
stuff they're just so glad that the
government's bailed on them out the
second group is the one that's like
listen I don't need government's help
I'm okay I've saved money
I already experienced a once a no one I
didn't want to experience it again I
already went through a no wait when I
lost a lot of money the real I told
myself that'll never happen to me again
I don't need the government's bill I'm
gonna be okay I've saved money I've been
preparing for this
I'm gonna be fine then there's a third
group of people that are saying I am
being forced to change and Pat I can't
stand it I don't like where I'm at right
now and the reality of it is we change
in two different ways one is by choice
one is by forced many people today are
being forced to change so those of you
that are in the third group or you're
saying I kind of want to make sure this
never happens to me ever again what do I
do
let me kind of give you a few things to
be thinking about number one these are
the time when you realize the skillset
of pivoting and adjusting whoever knows
how to pivot and adjust they have an
edge over everybody else just know most
people are gonna watch what everybody
else is gonna be doing a few people are
gonna be pivoting adjusting pivoting
adjusting with current times because
again we've never been through this
before to pivot and just that's one
skill set it's a mindset you got along
what to do the other part well
economically to talk about the income
protection is knowing what kind of
skills pay today for instance if you
don't know how to zoom you gotta learn
how to zoom if you don't know how to do
webinars you need to learn how to do
webinars if you're not a person that
facetimes a lot you need to learn how to
do face them if you're not somebody on
Facebook or social media or Instagram
that goes live you need to learn how to
do that if you're not a social media
person you need to learn how to do that
if you don't create content you may need
to learn how to do that if you don't
have a service to sell that's not a
physical product today maybe you need to
learn how to sell a service today if
you're not a good salesperson maybe you
need to learn how to sell today because
those skill sets are required today so
when this happens the income protection
the insurance policy for your income
protection is knowing that you know how
to make money when everything is fine
but you also know how to make money when
the economic growth of one hundred
twenty eight months in a row expansion
stops you also know how to make money at
times like this
because many people do so again first
group can help you watch all the movies
you want second group you don't need my
help you're already doing fine third
group pivot adjusts learn the skill sets
find the sir Sir it's find a service a
product that you can sell today and if
you're not getting sales go learn how to
sell today and in a year two years
thirty years from now when everything
recovers you'll look back and say you
know what I'm prepared
for the next one I don't want it to
happen but I just know every ten years
of crisis going to happen and when it
happens I'm definitely going to be
protected and the same thing is not
going to happen to me as it did in 2020
[Music]